and it's going to be exciting our dinner
guys he starts out with the white pieces
he wants to win this game here we go yep
1d4 a queen's Pawn opening this could
lead to a variety of different
variations what will Magnus choose okay
not what we expect maybe from the world
champion I haven't seen this uh this one
before from him too often he plays the
perk the modern okay it is the perk and
this could transpose
okay he doesn't go into the Philadelphia
defense
uh he's just letting white occupy the
center with his pawns yeah and uh Eric I
see developing the dark Square Bishop
he's getting ready to line up the queen
and Bishop and perhaps initiate an
attack
and there it comes King is getting ready
to run to the long side to the queen
side oh nice yeah we will see some fiery
stuff today cool and Magnus I think he's
learned some lessons from his game
against pregnant in the prelims of this
tournament Prague in a very similar
opening just went straight for Magnus
just attacked him and had a winning
position after about seven moves uh so
Magnus this time has survived the first
few turns at least the evaluation bar
still really liking white that's because
white has a space advantage in the
center and a development Advantage now
he's castled but black is super flexible
at the moment Simon who do you prefer in
these types of uh openings
um well I mean I play this as white and
black sometimes and it's I think
generally quite well known that the perk
is very very risky and when I say risky
probably a bit dubious at top level
there's a reason why none of the top
Grand Masters play it on a regular basis
it's still a great opening because it's
a really fun fun exciting opening and
you're you're guaranteed a very
adventurous and um interesting game and
we see this move now B5 coming on the
queen side
um and black has already has a threat
he's threatening to kick the Knight away
and win a pawn in the center so why it
guards that Paul in the center but one
thing for sure you know you get some of
the most interesting positions from this
opening so the right strategy I think um
from Arjun and I'm a little bit
surprised actually that Magnus has
played so aggressively you know because
he he showed that he can outplay in
normal positions and this is really
really you know you can't play more
aggressively as black than this opening
can you really it's a super aggressive
yeah provocative as well and
um I just had a flashback for a second
to a bit of deja vu I was thinking I've
seen something similar to this before
and actually in the prelims of this
tournament okay Magnus smiling that but
uh the prelims of this tournament in
round one Eric I see had white Magnus
had black and Magnus played the modern
defense which is basically uh kind of a
sister variation to this opening and
Magnus one is black so I think he's just
basing he crushed him he crushed him he
crushed absolutely crushed it yeah yeah
that game uh that game was partly due to
the fact that Eric icy had reacted too
aggressively so he's not going for the
same kind of approach here here he's
abiding his time he's solidifying the
center and uh now
is the moment to start pushing those
pawns or developing a light Square
Bishop yeah so white has various options
depending on aragaisy's move uh you
sorry not depending on his move his mood
and you mentioned a few options there at
Ivanka yeah so I just checking database
and I can see that uh the pawn push G4
is the main move closely followed by the
Light Square Bishop developing to the D3
Square Yep this makes a lot of sense
kicking back blacks well placed Knight
given the opportunity and the other move
is to bring the white Bishop out and
okay he doesn't choose either of those
those options he pushes Harry the H1
this one's slightly surprising to me it
looks like
um this is kind of a nice setup for
white if the Knight gets kicked back at
least you can retreat but uh the reason
I'm surprised by Eric icy's move is
because now exactly after what Magnus
has played he can't really use the
Central Square for his Knight where he
wants to place it because Black Knight
would jump in with a nasty Fork so
instead he's dropped back and
it's a pawn race I think I think this
has gone I mean again from having a bit
experience in these openings I think
this has gone quite nicely for Magnus uh
I I mean I'm even thinking Arjun may
have castled a little bit too soon uh I
know I know this is the main idea but
you are putting your king straight away
into a Zone where you can be attacked
and Magnus is not messing about I love
seeing Magnus attack because you don't
often see it and I love seeing it when
he plays Super aggressive because he can
play brilliantly Super aggressive and
most people just think he's like oh well
you know he's he's just this end game
brilliant but he can play every every
part of the game brilliantly and um well
this is certainly getting very exciting
isn't it already this position but
Black's made a lot of progress on that
Queen side yeah it feels like black is
ahead in the race white still needs a
few moves to prepare pushing his Pawn
forward maybe he needs to push this Pawn
forward as well and it looks like black
isn't really developed the king's still
in the center of the Bishop's there but
actually like it's really flexible
Black's King like you said it's it's not
committed so it
sit in the center it could Castle King
side Queen side later Black's Bishop
kind of stays on its start Square
because actually if it ever moves it
might just get traded off anyway by
White's Bishop so he's just kind of
Saving Time Magnuson
white tonight now coming out by the edge
of the board one thing I've seen Magnus
do before and similar positions is
actually just take this Knight off the
board with his Bishop just because black
is slightly cramped and this Knight
might jump forward into his this is some
this is like one of the Masters of this
line tiger Hiller person recommends that
move David quite a lot using the bishop
to get rid of that Knight and um it's it
has quite a lot of similarities to some
night off lines even this this opening
with uh the what the Black Knight and
the King side coming across the other
way
um but certainly going to be very
exciting I would just like to say a
quick look in in the chat
um to someone who has done the good
night yesterday and he told me his name
was raw like a tiger and um or or can I
just call him Mr Fireball man
I did I did spot him in the chat earlier
so uh um yeah he's certainly a character
and a good character
where was he from uh he was from Oslo
yeah but he yeah we had a yeah friend
that he knew um from the old time so
yeah because I noticed yesterday there
were a lot of uh oh wait what just
happened Magnus played a slightly odd
move I've got to say he's committing his
Pawns in the center he's just
encouraging Arjun to push forward even
further and go on the attack and
evaluation bar thinks it's good for
white it does look odd to allow this uh
we've got to say yeah I have to say if I
were Argent here and I'd face I faced in
this move then I would say you want me
to push forward that will be my pleasure
I am going to attack that Knight and uh
yeah Arjun makes that move and uh Magnus
is forced to put his Knight on the side
of the board yeah Black's Knight is not
very well placed here but it does remind
me of a variation they call the North
Sea defense but also the Norwegian rat
so in that opening it's very provocative
black asks wait to push forward as far
as possible then he places his Knight on
the side of the board and the main idea
is just to confuse the opponent right
Simon no totally and um yeah very
interesting decision there it's not
really like the perk to play that move
in the center which Magnus went for and
he's really dicing up today isn't he
he's taking he's taking some very
unconventional uh sort of view with the
game and he's playing some quite wild
moves and uh I mean that black knight at
the moment
um it well it was threatening to come in
but Arjun has stopped that night's jump
and uh yeah I'm I'm not that convinced
about magnus's plan because the night on
the rim uh yeah as you're showing David
it's just a target for Black's pawns a
white spawns white spawns would love to
come forwards and black I guess wants to
use his Knight on the other side of the
board to jump in but
um not totally convinced this is the
right way to play from for black for
Magnus it's very risky right and not
really what you want to be doing when a
draw is sufficient and well this is
magnus's deep point you see a trade of
the bishop for the night and then he
actually Retreats his Knight on the G7
Square which is usually where
a bishop finds itself but no and as
David highlighted Knight can blockade
the pawn or move to the F5 Square I mean
I suppose David If he if he can block it
up on the king side
um then he's going to be actually
Black's gonna be doing quite well if he
can use his H porn and the other Pawn
yeah this is what he'd love to do and
this is his strategy yeah if he's given
enough time as you say Simon if he can
put all these pawns on light squares he
can compensate for the fact he's traded
off his lights going bishop and yeah uh
black is Rock Solid here the Knight
coming forward
but this requires white to be uh kind of
agreeable and can white take advantage
before as you mentioned Black Blocks it
with these two porn moves
maybe there's a way I mean Prague he
plays a similar idea to pushing his Pawn
forward and sacrificing some material uh
when he played Magnus in the prelims
different position but similar ideas I
would be very tempted to look at pushing
this Pawn forward the Black Knight I
guess would take this pawn and prag in
that position sacrificed a rook for
night it looks like it shouldn't work
here but I mean there are ideas such as
pushing this Pawn forward or I love that
move David that you've pointed out there
already this Pawn Forge simply and then
pushing forward again and it feels like
you're getting so much time send me open
file but yeah yeah uh I mean it's just
uh it's a crazy position absolutely love
that idea because if you push the the
Gary Pawn here the G Pawn
I can still close it down by the looks
of it I I think uh with a very typical
response moving Harry and this is the
kind of thing black wants to keep it
closed there so I'd love your idea of
offering a pawn
um pawns don't matter so much when
you've got such sharp tactical positions
when when the kings are on opposite
sides of the board you don't worry about
pawns because it's very unlike you're
going to get to the ending Checkmate is
key so I think this is his chance right
I think he's got to now play
aggressively with confidence and push
that H Pawn and that will show that he's
he's here to play so
yeah I mean you have to do something
before Magnus okay he brings this bishop
out I was going to say before Magnus
gets his type of position where he just
slowly turns it into a positional
strategic battle and this one feels a
bit odd uh what's the bishop doing that
if the Knight moves
for example then you're just trading off
a bishop that hasn't actually moved at
all so white has spent two three moves
with his Bishop just to trade off I'm
not sure Magnus will even bother with
moving his Knight right now
um this Knight is protected
this looks a bit odd to me and uh yeah
what is this bishop doing here I guess
it just the main idea for erigga says it
stops black blocking it up with his H
Pawn I'm smiling because this is
actually my first instinct to put the
vegetable at the edge of the board and
uh yeah I agree with you I think it's
it's not a great move because like you
say the dark Square Bishop is actually
very good for white and bad for black
yeah because that was very stuck yeah
the dark squared Bishop from Agnes yeah
I mean if you rewind two moves uh here
before before he got traded off this
bishop was doing what yeah nothing at
all and also if you look at the pawn
structure in the center white has a bit
more space because he's pushed his pawns
further forward than black has therefore
black should be the one who's cramped
therefore black trading off pieces it
feels like it helps him
um I mean that's not to say that arjun's
position is bad but maybe it's just less
good than it was maybe at the moment has
passed to really start attacking and
Black's night's actually pretty good
right now
yeah that's a good Pete and white will
be struggling with actually his night
his
my starting Square it doesn't have any
exciting prospects either
and uh you
know is it true that you're only as good
your position is only as good as his
worst place piece
no no it's not really true isn't it
sometimes it's true at least at night
one day can uh develop itself takes a
while Arjun meanwhile maybe deciding
which porn why can't he do it right away
what am I not seeing yeah so he would
love to develop his Knight right now but
this would break the connection between
Waits rook and the pawn in the center
suddenly a pawn would drop off in the
middle of Black's Pawn uh Black's night
sorry is ready to capture this Pawn if
the white knight steps in the way so you
just have to keep your Rook defending
this Pawn that means you can't develop
your knight no say squares
it's not easy you would love to kind of
push this Pawn forward and then push
again and try to dislodge Black's night
in the center but right now this square
is covered by the Black Knight you just
can't really push you don't have any
control over the dark squares because
you traded off your dark squared Bishop
so it's kind of too late right now the
timing is off yeah I mean I'm still not
sure exactly what Magnus does maybe
Magnus moves his Queen and then
possibly eventually Castle's King on
this side of the board but uh
I mean the problem for arag I see is he
wants to win he has white and there's no
clear plan for him either
so one point about getting that dark
squared Bishop of Magnus off could that
have been that his King is on an open
dark Square sort of diagonally
I mean I think one idea is that the
black king can never Castle anymore on
this side of the wood uh it's not legal
because he's moved his Rook at the
moment he's safe ish diagonally but oh
I'm sorry I meant the white king ah the
white king yeah yeah so why Arjun wanted
to get magnus's dark squared Bishop off
the board yeah quite possibly although
if white say had his Dart score Bishop
still on this Square then there wouldn't
have been any checks on this diagonal
anyway
um it just feels like he would love to
kind of have his Bishop back here so he
could push some pawns that's
guys uh maybe I'm being a bit critical
of everybody's decision but well the bar
definitely did go down with that move
and he has been thinking now for three
minutes do you think he's regretting his
decision possibly and struggling to come
up with a new plan I mean for example
you can push Harry the H porn but what's
it actually do even if uh even if black
ignores it
uh okay you've got to send me open file
for your Rook but you're not really
going anywhere with it
yeah it's uh it's all about this piece
perhaps huh yeah I mean I don't I don't
think it's that bad I mean like the the
uh if I was white here again I'd be
thinking exactly the way that's a weird
move
I was going to say I'd be thinking the
way you're you're saying trying to make
some break it's still a very aggressive
position in my eyes as in both kings are
quite fragile so I'd be trying to break
through and I'd be trying to push what
is the F Pawn in this position but I
don't understand that Rook move you
don't you know any little time losses is
is not good the only explanation I can
come up with is that he wants to push
this Pawn forward now and then now the
square which was used by The Rook is now
opened up First bishop but nope now we
move sorry
maybe that Rook movie was to do with
nope I have no explanation I know I kind
of try to work it backwards no I mean I
don't think the night jump was doing
anything and here we go now Magnus is is
the first in it it looks to me to open
up the opponent's king it's all about
who gets the the opponent's king first
in these sharp positions and uh White is
kind of uh pushing on an area of the
ball where not much is happening as
David had shown and Magnus is directly
opening up his Queen towards White's
King and with two knights and a black
Rook backing that up this this could get
very dangerous to White very quickly I
think it already is dangerous you can't
waste time in these positions you know
you can't play little Rook moves like
that you know you can do it when the
position is a lot safer but this is not
a safe position and now Magnus has the
setup with the pawns that you were
advocating for Arjun right layer exactly
always push on the side you're stronger
or push towards your opponent's king
that's kind of good strategy and as
Simon said this Rook move it's also on a
very loose Square it's not protected
just indirectly I'm a bit worried about
some tactics on this diagonal later on
um also it's really fascinating to me
that Magnus okay the pawn takes Pawn was
played but he's just allowing a check
with White's Bishop we talked about
Kings on open diagnose but I think
magnus's idea was just to ignore it just
move his King and he doesn't care that
it's a check because his King actually
will hide safely later on but uh let's
catch up with the game we saw a trade of
Pawns
and another Trader bonds and yeah
suddenly already danger against the
white king
looking dangerous yeah it's yeah I mean
you've got you've got two nights with
black ready to come in you've got a rook
um okay well Arjun is going for this
plan again his light Square Bishop out
which does make some sense if if he can
come and maybe capture the Black Knight
he opens things up a little bit but
Magnus is now to strike first you've
also looked at magnus's pawns on the
queen side now he's got two pawns which
are really close to the white king and
you can you know it's called The Pawn
storm you use these pawns to basically
leave her open your opponent's defensive
position okay well first of all the
white Rook at least has a has something
it's doing now it's stopping Checkmate
otherwise Queen takes Pawn would be
Checkmate so it has some use yeah but
I'd really like a Black's position
Ivanka to say and there's already isn't
there a big threat of actually jumping
in with the Knights of the D4 rein
forcing the threat against that poor C2
Pawn but also at the same time a knight
on D4 would attack the F3 Pawn
and
yeah maybe I can play A3 when your
knight comes there
I mean for example
I don't get the humor it's really weird
chess geeky humor
it's just like oh my words is actually
really geeky yeah it could happen though
uh Simon basically by pushing this Pawn
forward has weakened this Square so the
Black Knight can actually deliver
Checkmate uh the king is what we call
smothered
um it's kind of suffocated behind its
own pawns and uh you can't take this
note because of a pin on the C file
there was also a second Checkmate idea
yeah yeah Queen takes porn giving up the
queen and again the king is trapped
because its own pieces are taking away
its Escape squares wow this is scary
stuff Arjun very quickly played that
move
um wait one second can you kind of oh
you wanna go B3 first can you do weird
he moves like porn and be free
I love it I love the I love the analogy
weirdy moves
we want weirdly moves we want weird he
moves give us the weedy
what am I saying
so the Night comes in that's a lovely
idea though it's tempting you're
threatening again this Knight takes porn
Checkmate the king trapped but you're
also threatening this Checkmate when he
takes porn and as we just showed in that
variation the king will be trapped again
uh but I guess the problem with pushing
this Pawn is black earlier is that this
squares now three four white pieces but
the Knight can jump to this F3 I mean I
I'm not sure maybe I'd probably be happy
to give up material anyway but maybe the
White Queen can block uh on the Square
and kill the fun Queen exchange will
make the white king safer oh
this feels like the idea needs like
fine-tuning and we might be it's it's
very close so close it is so close I
agree and like you know here what you
know just that was so close to that
position as well there was some crazy
ideas there but
this whole idea the night coming in is
is terrifying isn't it I mean but you
can also build up a little bit here I
mean you've got you've got a spare move
because White's last move doesn't really
threatening anything it doesn't you know
again it's a little bit slow so black
has a spare move here wow Magnus jumps
in immediately so he's threatening to
making two moves Queen takes four is a
massive threat needs to be defended
against
you need to either push this port
forward one square which looks really
risky or you need to defend it I mean
can you try to counter attack I mean if
I was white here I'd love to whip that
Knight off
um I don't know sacrifice yeah I have to
say there's only one only one way okay
you can defend and the position is gonna
get crazy right okay it's the only way
that white can Defenders to move the
queen to the F2 Square
and then the move that we were looking
at that I called weirdy is gonna might
appear on the board wow threatening all
sorts of checkmates and water position
again Pawn takes Pawn allows a night
Checkmate smothered mate and uh yeah
just to show your idea Ivanka uh Queen
takes night it looks like Black's
blundered but
um at the very least Queen sacrifice
again and a Checkmate just with a rook
and a pawn
incredible incredible lines there
beautiful stuff I mean how does in that
last line the computer might say this
this queen move is okay for white but
how on Earth does white defend after
that pawn push and obviously Arjun will
see this but it's not easy if you
haven't got the computer running to
survive here exactly and as David
highlighted that is the only move for
survival wow so white basically just has
to ignore that there's a big Pawn on the
B3 square that is so difficult you have
to let your opponent get one square away
from promoting and making a new Queen uh
I guess the White Knight comes back and
captures but it still looks so scary so
scary would you guys find that F2
sitting there
we will find it in a heartbeat I don't
know I mean it's the type of move uh
sorry in this position after then I came
in it's the type of move I would look at
but I would still be terrified okay and
I wouldn't be able to I mean without the
evaluation bar in front of me I would
have no idea I would still be
50 thinking I'm about to get checkmated
as white so yeah um but I mean I suppose
I I reckon he will find it because
there's maybe no other option yeah I
mean I was looking at giving up the Rook
which was a bit desperate to be honest
because uh it is a whole exchange but I
was actually getting very very scared in
this position of there's a couple of
checkmates on the board front I mean if
you try to move the bishop to defend it
this is the only other move I can see
you can think of this just looks like
it's not going to work somehow B3 comes
anyway and it's the same kind of thing
as we saw but you know you want your
queen more active so I think it happens
yeah and and yeah you can just win the
exchange so he has to find this queen
move and he will find it I'm confident
he will find it anyone want a little
cheeky bet there anyone thinks he won't
play the queen move
yeah he plays it and well just to
celebrate but a very calm composed move
I'm going to share with you a tweet from
Jimmy Cecil who says
well I'll bring it up you'll see it's a
meme okay oh well I do yeah memes are
good but I love memes and if you two
also want to join in the fun because
it's the final day uh well you can tweet
your picture your Tweet Tweet to uh
using the hashtag chess Champs and we
see Arjun Pusher porn food Ivanka you
mentioned there was only one move to
survive that was bringing the white
knight in oh yeah there it goes up yeah
I mean that that makes no sense because
important I mean I don't understand that
move at all
you I'm sorry I mean he
why would you play that movie because
it's very scary to it's scary yeah I
mean you got it but
I mean surely now black has a number of
what it'd be more than one way to to get
a major advantage now yeah his idea I
guess after Pawn takes porn hitting the
white rook and hitting the White Knight
is that the Rook will move catch a black
snide and after black makes a new Queen
this is weird I've never seen a double
check with two different Queens hitting
the white king luckily the white king
can take one of the queens and uh maybe
the white King's surviving again another
check but the king moves
oh it's just about it's hanging by a
thread but I can't see a knockout blow
here for black
uh so in the current position I guess
the reason he pushed his Pawn to the
square sometimes he wants to support his
Bishop coming in with a counter attack
hitting the black king
but yeah I mean firstly what happens if
you just take the spawn
um
okay he takes for the queen Magnus
Carlson very nice and uh after a queen
trade which way is he going to take here
with his Rook with his Pawn or his
Knight he takes with a knight wow lining
up a discover check if the Black Knight
jumps out the way this king is going to
be in big trouble
now he's also won a pawn Magnus so he's
attacking and he's a pulling up
but at least for Arjun the Queens are
off right at least now the Queen's uh
there won't be as many checkmating
threats to deal with
I suppose you can move his Bishop in
with a check now that that could be a
bit useful so uh yeah I mean I I was a
bit critical that move but to be honest
it's such a hard position for white to
play
I mean uh we saw there are multiple
checkmates he has friends check-in uh
that that white was facing and um at
least now he's got a little bit of
initiative hasn't he but he's attacking
the pawn and Center Magnus defends it
well that there goes the initiative yeah
at least out of half a move he had one
threat Arjun it's blocked and Magnus is
just a pawn up also this Knight looks a
bit weird but it's probably just a
strong piece
uh yeah it's hard to bet against the
world number one now extra pawn and big
advantage
it's uh looking very good for Magnus but
uh we do believe in Arden's defenses
absolutely yeah it has to be four
minutes left on the clock for Arjun
Arabic oh and here's the uh here it is
stay calm and play chess and I thought
that was quite appropriate because you
found the best defensive move so thank
you Jimmy I know what this is from this
is like I think it was the um Norwegian
uh Norwegian Grandmaster who's on
Twitter quite a lot he said that Arjun
is so calm he would be calm drawing a
nuclear attack but I was kind of
thinking maybe that's not very
appropriate this time in current history
yeah anyway yeah knock on wood
yeah
he has survived the storm that Magnus
threw at his position there and uh it's
just about the damage that's incurred
long time yeah okay retreating with the
white knight I like that move actually
just getting ready to jump into the
center later if uh if possible
like this still has
a lot of work to do to be honest yeah
why it's at least blockaded up the
attack yes these are Pawn down but that
night is is heading to a Central Square
and quite a lot of positions maybe you
can Retreat that night as well the white
knight uh that black B3 Pawn the black
Intruder in the white half that is
actually unprotected white tonight could
go for that pawn later
if that pawn drops suddenly all three
results are once again possible will
that be a focus for minus in this ball
then to find some way to protect his uh
b-pawn yep I think Magnus will want to
improve either his Rooks or maybe
improve the other Black Knight the Black
Knight in the white Camp looks good you
don't necessarily want to move it
uh competition's curse maybe jumping
backward that night is actually one of
the best moves but uh I would be very
tempted to jump in with the other Black
Knight as well just bring more pieces
into the
uh into the game yeah I like the way you
think David is very harmonious and uh
because I'm just looking at the one move
threats I'm like yeah let's let's set up
a check mate because after all the white
king is uh in a cage especially by that
created by that B3 Pawn so I was like
well can we can I share it David yeah
yeah of course so this is the idea that
I have now okay obviously white as well
is playing but I was thinking just line
up The Rook to the Rooks on the c-line
and then say I make a move yeah and then
I uh double up and then the whole idea
is that if you make a random move
then I wanted to put my knight on the
very flashy square at night to D4 wow no
that doesn't work that's a terrible move
I don't know this is okay so let's say
last move I'd move my knight yeah yeah
then academically works and then Rick
takes and you want to come down yeah and
the idea is basically the white king is
weak on the back rank because it's kept
caged by this black pawn cutting off its
Escape squares so maybe not in this
exact way but it's definitely going to
be a theme for the next few moves and uh
Magnus okay he doesn't double up his
Rooks on the C file instead he tries to
change direction and he challenges this
white Rook which makes sense it's on an
open file if we see a train of Rooks now
blacks Rook has a clear path into
White's camp
to what's half
this is a much better way to keep the
white king caged
yeah I like it this is Magnus showing us
why he's the world champion
it's very nice in huge trouble now
I mean he's been in trouble for a while
I mean I would say this is better than
it was maybe a couple of moves ago uh
that's the only positive thing I can
think of um still hold the H file maybe
just defend his Rook yeah
it's one thing I noticed with this final
um is that first of all Magnus is
looking a lot Slicker you know he's done
his hair up you know he's jailed it up
he's wearing a very smart jacket yeah
and um he's really you can see just his
body language he really wants to I think
not just win this match but you know
just put some dominance on his opponent
and I think that's like when you have
these young brilliant players come
through like arjan and I don't Magnus
said he hasn't played him many times in
the past it's like you've got to show
how strong you are in your first couple
of encounters you don't want them to
start getting their confidence up
because they're only going to get better
and I think this is
one reason we're seeing Magnus really
dominating this match as well it's not
just arjun's play it's Magnus really
wanting to exert his you know like like
the animal kingdom isn't it I I am the
lion you know I am the jungle that's it
I'm the alpha Magnus you Young Lions
coming through you're not quite there
yet
um but anyways moves in the game here
David is it anything do you think
changed much yeah I mean it's it's
interesting I still think black's doing
very well but uh at least white is going
for that B Pawn and uh White Tonight is
ready to capture it in a moment white
Rook needs to move out of an attack
first and it's a bit of a dilemma for
Arjun if he kind of shifts his Rook on
the first rank which he does then it's
still a passive piece uh if he had
brought it up the board then the first
rank would have been vulnerable later
when blackstruck comes in now I'm
expecting Magnus to start
definitely going for White's pawns on
the right half yeah I thought maybe his
plan was to jump in with the Knights
okay the second night and uh Target
it's a beautiful
can we I mean give me those cheapos I
love it I mean one of my favorite check
Mates is a night Checkmate and uh this
would be double Nightmare and so nice
Checkmate wow two nights alone and a
pawn trapping the white king whoa yeah
that is a unique threat
um I guess it already guys he will spot
it after the Knight comes in he'll spot
that this is a threat he'll capture the
black pawn but still you maintain the
threats right yeah The Rook comes down
to the second row and uh this was the
big idea yeah I I don't really see how
to save this Pawn to be honest you can
take away one Black Knight but the other
night replaces it
and still this Pawn attacked I guess
eragite's only defense is to try and
play for tricks maybe move his King out
the way if the Rook takes the pawn now
then there are ideas such as jumping
away with the White Knight and the idea
is to deflect this Black Knight to try
and trick it to move because it's forced
to defend his Rook
now some saving chances perhaps still
looks pretty bad for white but uh yeah I
mean I guess this is what he's relying
on Magnus just weighing up maybe looking
for other moves but this one looks good
enough
for some type of Advantage at least
nice time Advantage as well for Magnus
at the moment with Arjun just in two
minutes and two and a half minutes oh so
uh yeah tough I mean if he loses this
game it's going to be so tough because
we have to remind everyone that if
Magnus wins the first two games it's
over yeah it's over so he's got white in
the next game if he wins that it's
completely finished yeah so yeah and if
Magnus wins is yeah Arjun will have to
win two games against the world number
one
that is a lot to ask and we have to win
a game with black as well you know which
makes it even harder and we see we see
okay so some but the B Pawn is off
e-born is off so Arjun can breathe a
cyber relief temporarily but uh Black's
Rook is active Black's nights in the
game he's trying a similar trick to
something we just showed I guess uh the
white king moving out
um of the way so instead of jumping in
with this Knight he jumped back that was
a capture The Rook came in attacking
this pawn and White's King moved so
again Rook takes Pawn may be met for
example with a capture of the night and
then a capture of this pawn and Black's
Knight
Foster defender's Rook cannot really
move
um I mean at the very least here black
could just move his rook and probably
just win a pawn at some point but maybe
Magnus looking for more in the current
position so this is the position does he
take this Pawn or does he just for
example go hunting on the other side of
the board you could make an argument for
moving the rook and trying to capture
this Pawn at the base of White's Pawn
chain if this Pawn drops then this ball
might drop then this ball might drop
mopping up
business start from the back that's what
you said yesterday when taking pawns off
definitely this one is the weakest one
so maybe start with that
that's the move I actually expect from
Magnus right now the other one just
requires a bit of calculation and
maybe it's good enough but
Magnus with five minutes
wow okay this one I don't I definitely
didn't expect that on your radio Simon
you know what I was thinking I'd want to
play G5 and I want to get my king in
behind it so I was actually like
I thought it was too stupid to recommend
things I can't say that I'll get laughed
at it you know but it's not so stupid to
play that kind of idea it's similar to
what you you mentioned there David of
coming around towards those pawns and
it's the only piece which is not doing
anything and what what is your opponent
playing next and this is the important
thing that makes these kind of moves
possible asking yourself what is my
opponent's next move there's nothing
that obvious that white can do at the
moment
no but it does seem slow I mean it's
just I think it's the surprise the more
we look at it the more it looks great
for Blackstone right uh still at this
point eternally weak this Pawn very very
weak and uh black spawns all defended
yeah it just looks very dominant yeah
he's priming himself for maybe a rook
and uh porn and game I don't know
and uh okay aragaisy slides The Rook one
square and uh can I share with you a
question that we have from Muhammad
Farah who asks us why are we all wearing
black or is this just a coincidence
David is wearing Navy dark Navy but
Simon and me we're in Black all black I
only wear black is basically well so I
don't only have clothes but not black
I'm just uh I just love my black yeah
most important okay so now I had a
choice to do I had a choice between like
a burgundy or black and I was like
go buff go for black and looks what I
found also quite amusing was that uh
Arjun is wearing white and Magnus is
wearing black yeah yeah that was fun in
Dubai World Championship Match Magnus
would always wear
the same color suit I think it was as
the pieces he was playing with so black
suit and like a light beige one when he
had the white pieces yeah
chess humor even
yeah and uh Magnus miwa has gone one
Pawn up it didn't last for long Eric I
see winning a pawn himself and now I'm
expecting one of the Black Knights to go
and capture White's apron you don't want
to leave White's apron to survive
because it is a past Pawn
go and take that one away and flip on up
which night would you capture that porn
with because I was going to suggest that
I would take with the one on the second
row because then the two nights are not
tied
in some awkward construction and uh Eric
icy moves up The Rook two squares
yep I'm not sure exactly what the threat
is maybe the white Rook wants to come
across the board and start attacking
those Black Knights but Magnus does have
a move or two before any threats happen
to just re-coordinate his pieces he
doesn't look too happy the war number
one
a bit frustrated now changing position
it's funny Simon you mentioned kind of
the looking slick yeah but uh when I
studied medieval literature at
University there was there's common
themes of warriors in battle and how
before a big battle they grew like
there's this grooming ritual where they
you know they get their beards ready
they kind of
um they just make sure that they look
good they feel smart they feel ready and
I think it's the same address if you
look professional feel professional then
you play a lot better oh interesting
yeah wasn't the first chess piece the
island that was found the oldest chest
piece they found the Isla Lewis one yeah
has the Berserker chewing on the shield
right so that's indicating that they
used to uh take some
um substances before going into battle I
don't think so you know other things
yeah yeah so I learned a very
interesting fact about battles when you
have these kind of
um combats I learned that uh the people
who died were actually more often than
not by accident people went out there
and they got guns or whatever and they
just shot them up in the air and they're
just like they weren't aiming them at
people so like people didn't want to
kill each other oh in the battles and it
was all just either done by accident and
it was all just like Mayhem and
confusion oh but yeah because I always
thought it was like your Lord of the
Rings type you know the Paragon The
Killing Orcs yeah no it wasn't quite
like that there was not that much skill
involved maybe that's why I had they had
to groom they don't want their long hair
to be caught on it yeah it's by accident
but I guess you also want to look
intimidating into the enemy right yeah I
think maybe that's part of the reason
Magnus I've seen it happen in big
tournaments as well he wants to look
professional and then his opponents are
like oh he's come ready for business so
you do this David as well I I've noticed
and a lot of top players they say that
they wear suit to play a game of chess
because you've got to feel the part and
you wanna you wanna feel good when you
go into into battle and chess is a
battle after all okay so we have some
little tactics here we can see White's
idea with the Rook was to try and
activate it but Magnus is now done a
counter-attack with his Rook which seems
like quite a clever idea actually and
well black is a pawn up here and it's
just a matter of whether I guess he can
convert this the sexual pawn do you
think it's enough
it feels like it should be it's Magnus
yeah it is indeed also White's pawns are
pretty weak
Knights will start jumping in
and I guess you can start now White's
Rook is attacking one of the Black
Knights why not jump into the center of
the board
uh Magnus he looks he's like he's a bit
excited he feels like he's seen a good
move and he's going to play it I don't
really see any other move
seems very natural to use that Knight to
attack The Rook
um I mean it's a lovely lovely Square
for the Black Knight and you've also got
Central I mean this this is yeah there
we go I mean why not and just bring the
Knight into a beautiful square and
I guess if you can just get the other
night to a decent Square okay he's not
even doing he's not even bothering he's
just he's just trying to win a second
Pawn which is now undefendable and this
is this is really bad actually for for
white the problem is white is struggling
to get any counter play whatsoever and
the bishop is a terrible piece in such a
structure because all the pawns are on
one side of the board mean it's a close
range battle and Bishops don't really
work very well in these situations so
he's trying to bring his Rook now and at
least to try to get that Rook active
which which seems like the best bet but
um Magnus on the offensive as well of
his pieces there yeah
like two nights that are sniffing around
the white king as well and then you have
the Rook on the optimal second row it
doesn't even feel that white can
have the luxury of going on the
offensive and trying to stir up some
counter play
I mean I think he's trying the right
thing he is trying to get counter
playing in a in a desperate situation
trying to throw your pieces towards your
opponent's opponent's king but there's
not any threats yet and it is three
black pieces near the white King right
can black get it get the first mating
net around uh on the board exactly I
mean if you just move one night in the
king is trapped it literally has no
moves you just need to deliver one check
and it'll be game over meanwhile if
white gives a check it's just one check
right the king can move
I don't see what Eric is he's trying to
do to be honest is he trying to bring
his Knight that doesn't work but because
you have a nice covering but I like your
night move David because it you could be
trying to use that Knight to check and
then bring the other one in yeah looks
very close to checkmates might not quite
be I think it well if the white work
just uh leaves that line say for
instance it gives it yeah who knows
somewhere and then the other Nike front
E4 can take a step back
and then attack the bishop threaten the
very nice again double night Checkmate
looking at this position I think one
thing's becoming clear
what should Arjun do
yeah resign
just resign get the next game going yeah
[Music]
um
that would be a hammer blue to his
chances losing with white and again
Magnus he plays these openings and they
have poor reputations right or dodgy
reputations and he just makes them look
like
part of a great master plan it feels
like Magnus has had a game plan all
along just kind of survive on one side
of the board then start going for the
opponent's king
it's just kind of it it just has a start
a middle and an end all of his games
like this and this is another beautiful
movie isn't it because he's actually
just that Bishop which we've mentioned
the white Bishop is a really bad piece
okay gotta check in yeah well done yeah
you know and uh well he's giving up the
bishop now I mean I I I I don't think
there's a Checkmate for it here I mean
just not I mean but it's even tempting
just to ignore that bishop and Checkmate
go for checkmate after all it ends the
game it does there's one trap if you
move Black's night from the center of
the board I think that would backfire
seriously I think white might even be
winning uh or at least white would have
uh
oh actually I was about to say white
house uh very very good chances of a
counter-attack but the more I look at it
actually maybe not
so okay he just gets greedy why not take
a mission yeah he puts it in the bank
and uh rotates porn and the King takes a
step backwards there seems to be a trend
of Magnus he always takes the pieces he
can take yeah why not just put it in the
bank and uh save it for later and
surprise he didn't come forwards though
but I mean this this also seems
quite simple when they're good enough I
mean if white can't do anything in the
Rook at night then black is just going
to win now I mean so White's got to try
to use the rook and the Knight
to coordinate but you can't actually you
can't actually get anything going with
those two pieces here the black king can
always step forwards if it's checked and
uh there's there's nothing here at all
and of a couple of tracks but that's it
32 attacking pieces I have a feeling
well no I'm not I have a feeling black
is actually threatening to give a deadly
check mating threats getting very close
to that event can I mean like
you know what yeah there it is he
resigns our generic I see super tough
start to the final day a loss means he
now has to win two games do you have any
hopes of winning what a great game by
Magnus Carlson so here is today's Lisa
vetta learning point